Так на мою особисту думку, зараз пік моди на все українське.
Мені здається, якщо зараз не реалізувати бажання людей, люди розчаруються в мові
і закинуть ці бажання мати українськомовний органічний простір ще на сотню років уперед.
Тобто ми це реалізовуємо або зараз, або ніколи…
Студент Данило Гайдамаха - популярний україномовний тіктокер.
Хлопець перейшов на українську не так давно.
А тепер популяризує державну мову серед тисяч підписників у соцмережах.
Поза життям віртуальним Данило теж активно відстоює українську,
зокрема принагідно слідкує за тим, щоб нею користувалися у сфері послуг.
Я часто спостерігаю ситуацію, коли за столиком сидить людина,
до неї підходить офіціант і тоді ця людина, цей клієнт говорить "Excuse me, can you speak English?"
Тоді офіціант ніяковіє, намагається знайти людину, яка може говорити англійською, обслужити клієнта.
А якщо я приходжу в заклад і кажу "Перепрошую, чи не могли б ви говорити українською?",
мені скажуть "А вам этот вопрос принципиальный?"
Тобто я розумію, що напевно я десь  у своїй країні буваю гірший за іноземця.
Мені менш комфортно, ніж, напевно, англомовній людини в Києві.
І є місця і такі прецеденти, на жаль, до сьогодні.
Уже за місяць, 16 січня 2021 року, усі без винятку заклади,
що надають послуги чи продають товари: від магазинів, заправок і банків до барів,
аптек та бібліотек - мають перейти на українську мову у спілкуванні з клієнтами.
Таке зобов’язання містить одна зі статей закону про мову, ухваленого в 2018.
Разом з Данилом ми перевіряємо, чи готова сфера послуг до таких змін.
Зараз ми перевіримо, якою мовою говорять у транспорті.
- Можна, будь ласка, три квиточки? - Можна, чому ж ні. Так, тримайте. - Дякую!
Ще у трамваї Данило звертає увагу на інший аспект мовного питання у сфері послуг - вивіски.
Ми їдемо зараз транспортом і бачимо, що тут через раз насправді
і деякі заклади досі з російськомовними вивісками.
Цікаво було б зайти насправді послухати, якою мовою там обслуговують.
Сумніваюся, що вона буде українська.
Після перевірки транспорту вирушаємо до магазину побутових товарів.
Данило обирає його, бо раніше помічав у закладах цієї мережі обслуговування російською.
Я перепрошую, а ви не підкажете якісь жіночі подарункові набори.
Однак цього разу всі без винятку працівники магазину спілкувалися з нами українською.
Після мережевого магазину, де ймовірно є корпоративні правила обслуговування клієнтів,
прямуємо до яток у підземному переході.
Домовимося з вами так: якщо нас обслуговуватимуть українською,
то купимо троянду і подаруємо продавчині.
А якщо російською - то купимо дві гвоздички.
Можна, будь ласка, троянду? - Одненьку? - Одненьку, так.
- Дивіться, є від 30 гривень до 70. - Тримайте. Ось. Це вам! Дякую Вам за українську мову!
Данило наголошує: компліменти україномовному персоналу -
один із його інструментів заохочення до широкого вжитку державної мови.
Відмову ж обслуговувати українською хлопець теж радить не ігнорувати, але й не вдаватися до скандалів.
Якщо я побачу такий прецедент, то я краще звернуся до керівництва закладу,
аніж до персоналу, бо я розумію, що це не дієво.
Це лише спричинить якийсь скандал, а я хочу, щоб ситуація змінилися.
І для цього треба писати реальну скаргу. Всі адреси, пошти, куди звертатися, вони є відкриті.
У кожної компанії є сайт чи принаймні сторінка в соцмережах, куди можна звернутися.
Саме з допису в соцмережі розпочався мовний скандал довкола одного із популярних київських барів.
За словами відвідувачки, на її прохання спілкуватися українською бармен закладу відповів,
що йому зручніше російською. Це обурило дівчину, адже інцидент до всього іншого стався в День незалежності.
Цю ситуацію до такої ескалації можна було б не доводити, тому що конфлікт виник на рівному місці.
Звернулася до нас українською мовою, бармен відповів російською. Попросили перейти на українську,
він перейшов на українську. Далі виникло певне нерозуміння, що це відбулося якось некоректно.
Цей конфлікт ескалювався. І з нашого боку в тому числі було як мінімум два моменти,
де можна було б його уникнути. На жаль, конструктивних уроків мало, питання дуже болюче, і насправді шкода.
Тому що хочеться опиратися на якийсь досвід тієї ж Швейцарії, де є 4 мови, і це нормально все у людей якось уживається.
Юрій знає про вимоги до сфери обслуговування, які набудуть чинності з 16 січня 2021.
Зокрема починати діалог з відвідувачами і надавати їм усю необхідну інформацію тепер треба українською.
На думку Юрія, закон навряд чи суттєво змінить ситуацію на краще.
Глобально я не бачу причин, щоб щось змінилося, тому що є багато людей, які спілкуються українською,
і нормально сприймають, якщо до них говорять російською. Є багато людей, які спілкуються російською,
і нормально сприймають, якщо до них спілкуються українською.
Люди, які доволі конфліктно цю всю історію сприймають,
вони опираються більше на свої якісь внутрішні переконання, ніж на закон.
Конкретно закон дасть більше формальних приводів. Але я не думаю, що глобально буде більше конфліктів.
Хоча насправді хочеться розвивати українську мову не шляхом заборони всіх інших мов,
а шляхом якимось більш конструктивним, ніж деструктивним.
Мовний омбудсмен Тарас Кремінь наголошує: українська має бути пріоритетною в наданні послуг.
Однак жодна інша мова законом не дискримінується. За проханням клієнта його можуть обслуговувати будь-якою мовою.
Наразі ж в офісі уповноваженого із захисту державної мови вже півроку фіксують щоденні скарги
й звернення щодо російської в органах влади, закладах освіти та інших місцях, де, за цим же законом,
вже давно мала б звучати українська. Тарас Кремінь радить фіксувати такі випадки.
16 січня ніякого шоку для сфери обслуговування абсолютно не станеться. Якщо будуть радикальні порушення,
то починаючи від місця скоєння порушення, звичайно, можна попереджати продавчинь, кіоскерів про те,
що, будь ласка, надайте мені послуги державною мовою. Якщо після кількаразових попереджень
буде принципова позиція, звичайно, можна відкрити книгу скарг і пропозицій, однозначно можна зателефонувати на гарячу лінію.
Якщо і це не працює, то однозначно можна звернутися на адресу уповноваженого і викласти суть своєї скарги.
Але обов’язково треба зафіксувати аудіо чи відеодоказ того, що справді відбулося порушення.
Тим часом за пів дня, проведених з активістом Данилом Гайдамахою,
DW не зафіксувала значних порушень мовного законодавства.
Ми пройшлися загалом різножанровими місцями. Ми були в тролейбусі, ми купували квіти, ми пили каву,
ми спробували прожити день типового киянина. У багатьох місцях до нас спочатку віталися російською мовою,
але коли чули, що ми до них державною, переходили на українську. І це достатньо приємний факт,
тому що бачимо тенденцію. Раніше би не перейшли. Я був свідком того, що раніше не переходили.
У випадку відмови закладами сфери обслуговування спілкуватися з клієнтами українською мовний омбудсмен
чи його представник оголошуватимуть попередження.
Якщо ж ситуація повториться протягом року, то складуть протокол про правопорушення.
Штрафи сягатимуть від 5 до майже 7 тисяч гривень, але виписувати їх почнуть лише з 2022-го.